seid Elon Musk Twitter gekauft hat
überlegen viele der Plattform den Rücken
zu kehren und auch ich werde als starkes
Zeichen Twitter jetzt deaktivieren
also für den Dreh danach melde ich mich
natürlich mein Herz 200.000 Follower ich
kann ja das versteht ihr schon übrigens
83 Prozent der Abgeordneten Twitter aber
wo sind sie denn alle ach ja bei Twitter
poste ich halt doch noch was Liebe
Abgeordnete bin jetzt da kann losgehen
Herr Lauterbach da sind Sie ja hallo da
bin ich ganz genau twitter ist ja schon
auch Bestandteil ihres Lebens oder eine
ständiger Bestandteil ich lese da viel
also ich ärgere mich werde beschimpft
und beleidigt aber erhole mich dann und
Teile zurück alles gut wenn sie mal so
ein Abgeordneten Account sich anschauen
also ich weiß wovon ich rede da sind die
Beleidigungen schon ganz weit vorne und
ganz ihre lieblingsbeleidigung nee ner
wissen ich habe ungefähr bei fast jedem
Tweet den ich mache der kann noch so
vernünftig sein immer mal die Nachfrage
was ist eigentlich mit dem SED Vermögen
und ich finde sie inzwischen langweilig
das ist eigentlich mit dem SED Vermögen
ja das wäre ich Ihnen in der nächsten
Sendung verraten es gibt natürlich auch
viele ältere Abgeordnete für die Twitter
komplett Neuland ist guten Abend ja
hallo ich glaube das ist nicht eine
Frage des Alters sondern eine Frage der
Debatten also in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
zum Beispiel da ist Twitter jetzt nicht
so das bestimmte Thema der begnügt man
sich lieber mit der Lebensrealität jetzt
kann man ja sogar einen blauen Haken für
8 Dollar kaufen hätten Sie gedacht dass
der blaue Haken mal weniger wert sein
wird als der Doktortitel von Franz
Spotify oder blaue Haken wurde mir noch
gratis vergeben und die also Arbeit von
Franziska gibt halt die also er hat
hohen Wert von daher kann ich das nicht
mehr vergleichen sich denn vorstellen zu
Instagram zu wechseln und da wie Markus
Söder täglich essensfotos zu posten
macht er das ja Hashtag Söder ist wir
spielen mal ein paar Beispiele ein
[Musik]
das ist der Sie sich den Umstieg auf
tiktok vorstellen nein das würde ich mir
nicht mehr antun aber die
Bundesregierung hat auch mit China jetzt
wieder ein gutes Verhältnis
ist glaube ich weniger wir werden da in
der nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
machen haben verscherben dann können Sie
auch auf tiktok gehen aber sie haben den
schon ein bisschen verscherbelt Olaf
Scholz hat einen glaube ich 23
prozentigen Anteil Hafen verscherbelt
nein das haben
als FDP Abgeordneter
wir haben immer gesagt jetzt auch auf
tiktok deutschen Händen bleiben und den
Hamburger Hafen ganz übernimmt wenn es
nicht gut ich finde es nicht gut also
dass sie das so machen finde ich nicht
gut ja das können sie finden jetzt
konnte man hier live beobachten wie so
ein Gespräch auf Twitter übrigens
normalerweise abläuft okay könnten Sie
sich vorstellen als Zeichen gegen Elon
Musk Twitter zu löschen
nein die heute-show hier jetzt live
ihren Twitter-Account löscht dann lösche
ich meinen auch vielen Dank für das
Gespräch wir setzen das jetzt als
Zeichen gegen Elon Musk ja okay dann
machen wir das komm machen es komm wir
machen das aber warte ja ja normal ja
warte mal dann verliere ich ja meine
Follower ich werde mein Twitter Account
löschen ja aber ich mache das sicher
jetzt nicht gerade verlaufender Kamera
ja jetzt sind wir live dabei
wie sie ihren Twitter Account löschen
das ist ein historischer Moment und zack
ihr Twitter-Account ist gelöscht
ja da fühlen Sie sich frei ja ich muss
mir den ganzen Mist nicht mehr anzeigen
lassen also es klappt nichts mehr auf
und wenn Sie jetzt noch aus der SPD
austreten dann haben sie es geschafft
und mit dieser guten Nachricht zurück
ins Studio
[Applaus]
naja genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile
fast alle versteckten Symbole hier bei
uns im neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben
es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf Youtube
boah also ich würde mich ranhalten